prices for groceries rent and other
needed items continue to soar
the owners of small shops are
particularly hard hit as they see their
customers beginning to treat what were
everyday purchases as luxuries you can
see how the money flows
you can see
when people are not getting the extras
when they're getting coffee drip coffee
instead of cappuccino you can see it you
can see how they pay
if they're paying in coins
the increase in prices is now being felt
at every gas station
and in every grocery store
i just think we're a little more careful
i notice it in
almost every
product fruits vegetables which we buy a
lot of
deli products
i can't really see
anywhere that the prices have gone down
but they've gone up
bottlenecks in the supply chains of
distributors are the primary reason
and these in turn are the direct result
of staffing shortages as the pandemic
continues to rage worldwide
at this stage though the head of the
federal reserve insists there's no need
for panic that this is a temporary
situation
we will use our tools to support the
economy and a strong labor market and to
prevent higher inflation from becoming
entrenched
it's a similar message coming from the
white house which points to a dropping
unemployment rate as evidence that
economic recovery is underway
and is adamant that the supply chain
issue will be resolved we are well
positioned to attack the challenges of
prices and costs head-on
and that's exactly what the president
and this administration are doing
but republicans continue to blame
stimulus measures for overheating the
economy
one thing is clear it's impossible to
predict the ongoing economic impact of
the omicron variant surge which the
nation continues to face
i don't believe we've seen a peak yet
here in the united states the rise in
price increases reflect a harsh reality
that in the pandemic it's not just
people who get sick
but the economy as well mike hanna al
jazeera washington